and you know home
home for me now is is is you know for
the time beings and it's in this it's
interesting
and it really and it feels that way as
well so you feel like that's home more
for you yeah
prince harry is opening up about life in
america in the reunion with his
grandmother queen elizabeth
in a preview of his interview on the
today show the duke of sussex sits down
with hoda kotb in the netherlands where
harry and meghan markle are overseeing
the invictus games
this conversation comes shortly after
harry and megan's visit with her majesty
marking their first joint visit to the
uk following their notable royal exit in
2020
how did it feel
being back um being with her
being with her it was great it was it
was just so nice to see her you know
she's on she's ungrateful we always
she's always got a great sense of humor
with me and i'm just making sure that
she's you know protected and got the
right people well you make her laugh
that's what she always says uh did you
do it again yes yeah i did
make an irt with her so it was it was
really nice to catch up with her harry
opens up about life in california where
he and megan have been living with their
two children and you know home
home for me now is is you know for the
time beings and it's in this it's in the
states
and it really and it feels that way as
well does it yeah it's we've been
welcomed with open arms um and it's got
such a great community up in santa
barbara so
so you feel like that's home more for
you
as royal expert katie nicholl tells e.t
the homecoming also saw harry reuniting
with his father prince charles well
obviously it was hugely significant
harry and megan coming across the
atlantic the first time that they've
done this since 2020 and i think
particularly given that they weren't
there for the service of thanksgiving
for the duke of edinburgh harry very
much has wanted to see his grandmother
who we know has not been well he's been
in contact with the queen and um it was
understood that prince charles was going
to have a meeting with
harry and megan before they got to meet
the queen i think there was a feeling
that there just needed to be that
meeting between father and son before
there was a meeting between harry and
his grandmother so this was an
opportunity for them to well have some
have some one-on-one time with each
other there were just four people at
that meeting it was harry and megan
charles and camilla it was a short
meeting it was very much charles's
request that he had that meeting with
harry before harry went to meet the
queen he obviously had certain things he
wanted to say and obviously we all know
that a huge amount has happened in a
year so a brief meeting
a slightly tense meeting and probably a
lot of questions to to to to be asked
not enough time for for explanations for
everything but i've spoken to a source
close to the prince of wales who said
that while it was slightly tense it was
also very lovely for the prince of wales
to see his son he hasn't seen him for
over a year and the feeling is that this
has almost been a bit of an icebreaker
that first conversation difficult
conversation has been had
and they're hoping this will pave the
way for further discussions and
conversations and perhaps a thawing of
what has been an icy relationship up
until now
[Music]
you